you
[Music]
hi everyone so quick show of hands
before we get into this how many of you
are using some framework for managing
data pipelines okay and how many are
using shell scripts and cron okay all
right so this should be relevant to a
lot of folks I'm mark Weiss I'm a senior
engineer at beeswax and we're an online
advertising company here in New York and
my background just really quickly I've
been sort of an ETL and data processing
kind of space pretty heavily for like
last ten or twelve years so I've seen a
couple different permutations of this
problem space so we're going to talk
about a little bit about beeswax our
what our business does how much data
generates as Rick mentioned it's very
high volumes of data what our pipelines
are doing right now we'll drill into an
example and the idea is to show you that
using two two very different frameworks
and trying to leverage what they promise
and what we hope they'll give us what it
looks like to actually try to build that
example and those are gonna be air flow
and eight AWS data pipeline and we'll
kind of hit the reality checks of what
they do and don't do for us and then ask
and answer the question of like okay
well if they're not giving us all these
things
is it really worth committing to a
framework what do we get from it and
kind of wrap up by saying when you put
all this together and do the lifting you
need to do around the framework you're
living the dream so first let's talk
about these rocks just a bit what we do
and the data data flows so we're a
programmatic advertising company as
we've just mentioned so what that means
is you go to a website you open an app
there's an ad slot there the publisher
publishes a description of the ad it
gets sent to these exchanges who roll up
millions of these a second and Ford them
on to buyers of ads like us so we're
what's called a real-time bidder
that's our platform so our customers are
advertisers were buying ads for them
from the point of view of this talk
what's interesting is that this
generates a lot of data so we're just
breathing in this firehose of millions
of requests a second on the front of our
system and we have to respond to them
all really quickly just as a side note
that's one of the cool problems we have
to solve is a very high scale
decisioning very fast
so this generates a lot of data so the
bid requests are all these ads coming in
when we bid we log that when we win
that's called an impression we log that
later on a user clicks that's a
different event maybe two weeks three
weeks later they go visit a website
that's a different event so we've all
these asynchronous data streams that are
coming into our system so our main ETL
right now is written in data pipeline
and lands data in redshift and of course
probably like many folks here that's an
architecture that we're evolving past I
would say as a side note but right now
that's what happens and so one of the
challenges there is dealing with all the
scale and another challenge is joining
all these asynchronous streams and you
know also we have to do some tricky
things like figure out that three weeks
ago you saw an ad and now you're
visiting a landing page and those two
things are connected right so that's
kind of the current ETL you know and
then the okay yeah so this is also
showing there's a little out order sorry
about that this is showing the scale I
was mentioning so we've got you know
billions of the auctions coming in and
tens of billions of requests we log all
the requests and we've got hundreds of
millions of impressions and this data
isn't just for internal use this is core
to our product and our differentiation
so we have to handle all this gracefully
correctly with low latency the data has
to be fresh and that's because we
reporting is key in this domain for
customers they need to understand how
their campaigns are doing but also one
of the differentiations of our
businesses we deliver all this data back
to our customers as part of a flat
platform fee and so it's the data itself
is a key part of the product so the
other set of pipelines are newer of
course that's the airflow piece there as
we were disgruntled the data pipeline
and we're looking for something better
so they are we are basically just
building that's pretty typical use case
I hope that some folks here can relate
to extracting data from redshift landing
it in s3 building a data Lake
/ that that's holding the data for a lot
longer than we hold it in redshift so
that's using hive to do that so
basically right so one more slide here
just showing the growth of the data and
why we've been focusing on the data
pipelines you know why we were looking
for a better solution than data pipeline
and looking for a whole next-generation
way to handle this one reason I mention
the data's core to our business and its
strategic and we know we're going to
need to keep investing in that and it's
differentiation so we have to be nimble
there and be able to scale second reason
is just the business has been scaling so
this is this year and this is the
basically the top-line metric of
impressions so this is ads this is what
we do we buy ads so we're basically at
three acts start of the third quarter
from the beginning of the year and this
is a seasonal business so we know it's
gonna get even higher in q4 and so on
so we've good problem to have we have to
scale our pipelines so let's look at
this example let's revisit the data Lake
example and this is basically what I had
to do was say okay so what technology
should we use to build this data Lake
and you know again just really quickly
we need to extract the data from
redshift landed in s3 that's one step in
this pipeline and then another step is
to basically put a hive table over that
so data pipeline versus air flow so I
looked at a bunch of different choices
and it kind of boiled down to these two
data pipeline we'd already been running
for two-plus years we know how to run it
but we've the way that we ran run it is
we built a lot of our own tooling around
it so that ap eyes are pretty painful
even something simple as like figuring
out if a pipeline is already running
requires some gymnastics and so on with
the api's so and the UI is terrible
the retries story is ok but not great so
it works we know how to use it but we
weren't really happy with it and we felt
like we're spending a lot of time on it
it wasn't maybe a way to scale going
forward so we landed on airflow as Rick
mentioned like a lot of people are doing
it's kind of gotten it's clearly gotten
the traction
at this point it's the shiny object
right now it made it to Apache Incubator
and it's actually now the first hosted
pipeline service on Google Cloud and so
on so it was kind of the de-facto other
choice so we said let's see what we can
do with this so this decision felt a
little bit like this the first joke of
the presentation right data pipeline was
like a typewriter like we know we can
put paper in and hunt and peck and type
something that's about what we can get
out of it we're hoping that with a
higher learning curve and the shiny new
object can get a much powerful general
purpose tool for going forward right so
let's drill down now and like build haha
bill this is executable code build the
pipeline with these two choices and sort
of see where we land so leaving aside
kind of all the other aspects of
pipeline that are specific to just how
pipelines work and looking at our
specific requirements for this pipeline
we know we need to do these two things
as I mentioned we need to unload the
data from redshift s3 and we need to put
a hive table over it so one of the
promises of these pipelines that you
sort of hope for
especially with air flow which has
dozens of canned operators that it
provides and operators of the code that
actually perform the steps in the
pipeline you know you're looking at it
hoping to get some code reuse there and
not have to write this code yourself and
so the first question I wanted to answer
is was that going to end up being true
or not so let's look at air flow first
and you know the first thing that I saw
was oh look it's open source it's in
github and there's exactly the operator
we need redshift s3 so that seemed like
a really promising start but then when
we drill into the code right away we see
problems and this can be kind of the
theme of this part of the talk you know
for example the way it was handling
credentials wasn't the way we wanted to
there was no support for SSM which is
the way we do that everywhere and want
to do that so even right there in the
guts of the code it's not doing things
the way we want to and we would be
looking at forking at managing
Virgen something like that another
example of this was at that time the
version of airflow we're using then
didn't even support a passing an
argument to control whether or not when
you extract the data to CSV there would
be headers or not this is like a
extremely basic feature that you're
always gonna want to control and at that
time it wasn't supported so that's just
a small example of the brittleness so
the strength of this model is you have
these reusable operators you compose on
top of them at this high declarative
level and you can build out all whole
applications but the weakness is if the
operator doesn't allow you to
parameterize it the way you want that's
the only way you can change these
behaviors passing arguments to it when
it runs so if that's not exposed to you
you're stuck so similar and even worse
problems with data pipeline and this is
kind of cheating because we'd already
solved all these problems at this time
by basically writing all our own custom
way of putting pipeline Python shell
activities out and running them and data
pipeline but let's pretend so you know
if you look at what they offer out of
the box there these you there's this UI
a sort of visual builder which is
basically a non-starter because you're
pasting your code in there so that's not
going to work in terms of deploying
version code you can point it at scripts
on s3 and then you're building your own
tooling to extract from your repo and
land the thing in s3 so again you're not
getting this off-the-shelf
out-of-the-box kind of experience
furthermore you know they're just giving
you kind of these generic operators that
don't implement anything you used it's a
way to run sequel so you still have to
write the sequel so in that way you're
getting even less of an implementation
than with air flow right so basically we
took a look at these frameworks we tried
to do something with them and the first
thing we realized is the operators
they're giving us aren't giving us what
we need and as I kept digging in I
realized this was not just specific to
these implementations but this is
basically an attribute of how data
pipelines work the this model of
building applications and that this is
going to be true no matter
framework you pick so you know let me
back that up just a bit with some more
examples so just summarizing again sort
of what we found initially we couldn't
use these operators the way we wanted
because there were things we wanted them
to do that they either couldn't do or
they weren't doing them the way we
wanted these are the specifics so
authentication headers deployment
versioning but you know then I looked at
the rest of the way we build all our
applications at beeswax and you know we
were a business that several years old
we've been using Python in production
for years air flows all Python so the
hope was we've have the seamless
integration path but you know the truth
is you operate a big part of your
applications running in any cloud
environment or really anywhere is all
the rest of what makes them a production
so how you do monitoring how you do
logging how you handle errors all these
things and you want your pipelines to
run the same way ideally because they're
it's a lot less valuable to have this
general-purpose system to declaratively
put computation out in the cloud if you
have to do everything differently just
for this thing it's much nicer if you
can leverage and operate it the way you
run the rest of your stuff right so in
this example we always like to omit
certain metrics to in flux we rely
heavily on it for dashboards for
monitoring for on-call support all all
that kind of stuff also we have metrics
driven alerts so we need to be able to
do that and so there is some support for
this kind of thing in airflow with hooks
hooks let you wrap events and you can
write custom hooks but you're limited to
responding to the events that that you
can respond to you can't just put code
exactly where you want it in the
operator implementation you and also
then you writing your own hooks you're
now managing and maintaining your own
code once again already even if you're
trying to reuse their code and you know
it's a so basically you're not getting
all that benefit that you want and then
you know the second example of sort of
alerting this page our duty example on
the right
let's say you want to emit a message
from right from an exception block
because that's where you have all the
context and you can write that rich
message of exactly what failed and omit
the exception itself stacked trace all
that stuff you know you don't have that
kind of hook in any of these
implementations you need to be writing
your own code to have that kind of
control
right so and the last thing is you know
we want to import anti-gravity and fly
right of course you know joking aside we
had as I said we had all this Python
code to do and we'd solved all lots of
problems already right so we have our
three clients and paid read clients on
and on and on and we want to reuse all
that and we you know we want to just
import that in import etc import beeswax
dot and use it but there's no way to do
that at all with AWS data pipeline and
with airflow you have a plug-in API you
can wrap things and implement their
entry point their plugin entry point and
then again you're maintaining shims
you're maintaining the separate way of
integrating your code you don't have a
path to just build these applications
just like all the rest so that's the
first reality check a rather probably
long way around making the case which is
that the more you look at this operator
code you're just gonna the more reasons
you're gonna find that it's not going to
work for you so I would assert that if
you're looking at this problem space and
you're looking at building out a data
pipeline platform for your company you
should expect implement your own
operators and in fact just embrace that
right and you know again this is why
because this is code that is the only
way you can parameterize its behavior is
by passing arguments to it when it runs
so you know it unless everything is
exposed to you exactly the way you need
it you're not going to have the control
you need so we just decided to take this
problem head-on through a simple
inheritance pattern right so we just
basically put our base operator over the
airflow base operator and wrapped up all
the plumbing that needs to make
operators work with airflow
pick up the arguments that in the way it
wants pass them in and all that in our
base so our users don't have to think
about that and then we know everything's
gonna work with airflow flow is gonna be
able to trigger our operators and then
you know the nice thing about this also
is this gives us a really nice to level
pattern for laying in the general
services as that I was mentioning so for
example if we want the same metrics to
be written by every operator with the
same dimensions tagged on them and so on
same semantics we can put that in the
base class and then now for free all the
operators we write are gonna emit the
same metrics so for example just simple
things like duration of the tasks and
success or failure count those kinds of
things and then likewise if there's
services that we want to lay in to a
specific operator that required its
context we can put them at that level so
that's just an example of how to address
this problem an example of how we
addressed it but the idea is you should
expect to address in a way that works
for your needs and works with what you
already have
right so second example of where you're
gonna basically need to do lifting
yourself is sorry is deployment
packaging deployment all that stuff
right so here's our example again just
as a refresher you know so the basic
idea is these pipelines are a lot more
than just the dag which is the
description of the steps that run start
to end
and the little Wikipedia dad picture
there you know it's all like all the
rest of your software it's everything
that has to that you need to do to put
it out in production and run it
somewhere for real right so you know at
a very very high level the pipeline
model is that you've got this dad which
describes the steps you need to execute
you've got the configuration which
passes the arguments to it at the time
it's invoked and run and all the rest of
the code dependencies that it's going to
run all that needs to be somewhere and
it needs to run somewhere so this is a
high level
extremely high level sorry simplified a
picture of what this looks like an air
flow
or an approach to it so you've got to
figure out how to package as I mentioned
put that in a container for example
let's say you're gonna run things that
way somewhere and put that on a host
somewhere that's the code that's gonna
run with airflow you're also responsible
for putting the whole airflow service
somewhere else
so that's on some other host may be the
same host there were simplest models to
put everything all in one place and
airflow in fact has three processes that
you're thinking about running there's
the scheduler there's a web app and
there are workers so the simplest model
is all of those are on one host even
with your code you could put you could
do that not that's how we started but
even then you know you also need to have
separate my sequel that airflow uses for
the scheduling state Redis for the task
queue which are actually the it puts
these tasks up that the workers then
consume and that's how the pipeline
actually runs so you need all this
infrastructure configuration I need to
do all this stuff yourself and then you
need to keep it up and running right so
AWS despite the fact that it's a managed
service by name as soon as you get out
of the the trivial support it has for
doing things within what it what it
offers fully managed you're doing a lot
of the same stuff yourself you you're
figuring out how to package your code
and put it out somewhere on a container
so we do that in ECS right now you're
running this separate process called the
task runner which is an AWS application
that you configure to point to where
your containers are so what you're
getting out of the managed service is
really largely the same thing as what
you get from airflow which is a
scheduler and a UI and it's a painful UI
so it's sort of second reality check
which is this is not serverless yet
maybe some other speakers will address
that or have and it's not no ops like
you need to do all the same things you
need to do with the rest of your
applications and you're going to want to
do them probably the same way because
there's no value in doing them
differently and there's a lot of value
and having this thing run the way the
rest of your stuff runs so
okay I just spent the first chunk of
this talk talking about all the things
you're not going to get from the
framework providing some specific
examples so is it worth using one of
these and I would argue it is these are
sort of very high-level obvious reasons
why you know basically this whole domain
its generic right that's in fact the
entire value of it and the entire point
of it is this general purpose way to put
processes out somewhere out in
production and have them run and to use
it some this high-level declarative
means to do so so you want this general
thing but a lot of the aspects of a
pipeline system are general and not
differentiating for your business so
scheduling is really kind of the most
obvious example of this problem that
seems beguiling ly easy that you want to
solve yourself but you should not
because it has edge cases and it's also
a mature problem that has been solved so
don't solve it and scheduling is the
same for everyone daily as daily you
know also this idea of oh it's just a
dag library I can do that I'd learn that
in school etc but there's a the whole
full solution is a lot more than a fun
little dag library right so another
argument I would say for picking a
framework is just to pick one because
you know what we found over being a
fast-growing startup over the last
several years is this is a really
obvious pattern of you've got data here
you need to do some computation you need
to land it there like basically this
whole anything that's not a streaming
use case or an online transactional use
case or sort of a web app which is a
form of transactional use case is this
use case of like a process needs to
start up and do some stuff and then stop
and we need to know did it succeed and
then probably it depends on other
processes and and all that that's a
whole separate problem but the idea is
you're gonna rewrite this over and over
again so that's probably not that's not
high value because this mechanism
mechanism itself is generic in general
so just pick something commit your
engineering effort to that platform
getting better and better and being more
useful across your organization across
your services and you can bake in as I
was mentioning earlier all these aspects
you can bake them in and have it do
everything the way you want it can do
logging the way you want monitoring
alerting security all that so it's just
worth picking something and and you know
you do get a fair amount and again it's
all sort of general stuff that there's
not a lot of value in building yourself
you get scheduling you get an API for
defining DAGs and we can argue about
whether the airflow way of doing it in
this sort of almost pure Python that
isn't exactly doesn't exactly work like
that whether that's the best approach or
a visual approach or whatever but in the
end it doesn't matter that much because
it's you you get you have an API to hit
for doing that you don't the design that
yourself build out yourself manage that
code yourself and again even though you
don't get the whole runtime environment
you get a target to hit right so you
don't have to figure out the
architecture there's an architecture
that's basically given to you for you
for any of these frameworks you pick
what config you need what environment
variables what supported in terms of
where it can run what are the supporting
services it needs so you have a you know
you got the boxes and arrows already and
you know what you need to build and so
you're starting there you're starting at
a higher level and you know if you hit
that target it should work right you
also get everything about pipeline
semantics to one degree or another you
know so you have policy for what happens
when one task fails should the next one
run or should it stop should it wait or
can it start right away so you you
actually in have especially an airflow
which as rich policy around this stuff
you know you have a concurrency policy
at the same time as sort of task failure
policy just and how how you can define
the behavior of the deck you get retries
and both the pipeline and data pipeline
and airflow handle retries pretty well
airflow has very robust support for
backfill it's been one of the features
I've been most pleased with so it does a
really nice job of keeping track of all
the jobs that are supposed to run ever
and if they fail it keeps trying to
rerun them it's also really nice in
terms of you can stop it in the middle
and it will pick up from where it left
off and all this sort of thing and these
are all things that are generic to how
you
pipelines to work they're hard to get
right and it's done for you you know and
the last thing is you get this you I I
should have shown you the data pipeline
UI but I wanted didn't want everyone a
run out of the room you know so I just
I'm showing you the airflow UI but the
idea is you get this nice UI it lets you
look at status it lets you manage these
things manually you can go manually
retry things you can jump to the logs
all this sort of stuff airflow also has
reports on how long things have been
running and all this sort of thing built
right in so you know again this is a
whole web app they you don't want to
build yourself because it's just general
to managing pipelines you just want
someone to do it for you right
so not running quite full-time we're
almost to the end here but basically
wrapping up the idea so what do you get
when you put all this together you take
the pieces you get from the framework
you build out the other pieces you need
which are basically going to be the
actual code that's gonna execute the way
you want doing all the things the way
you want integrating the rest of your
code the way you want and some kind of
set of solutions for putting that out
into production and running right and
you know I was at a meet-up recently and
I think the trend one trend that's
happening is people are moving to a
higher level declarative abstraction
around air flow or another tool another
framework that encapsulate all of this
right so so give enable data scientists
or data engineers customers of this
platform the ability to just
declaratively say I want this pipeline
to run I want it to pull data from here
I want it to land data here and that's
it and then boom it runs so once you get
to that point and that's the path we're
going down to and that's the path I've
been on much of this year on and off
sort of wrapped learn figuring out how
to wrap air flow and get what we can out
of it but you know if you get all the
way there it's really powerful because
now you've sort of taken this DevOps
idea you could say of declaratively
saying what the end state is you want in
production of something and you've moved
up the stack to basically being able to
declare a full application now not just
infrastructure right
it's infrastructure plug
computation and even more so this idea
of having the operators be Jeanette
generic and know how to for example like
I know how to talk to redshift and run a
query and being parameterize by config
you can compose new applications then by
composing the operators in different
ways and giving them different config
and again you're not writing any new
code now you so you've got this very
powerful framework I would even argue
that it's more powerful than that
because so far this model or this wave
thing about building applications is
largely focused on the data domain but
there's no reason to limit it to that
operators can do anything and as I
mentioned earlier you're going to be
seeing this pattern you you have this
pattern all over the place of writing
these back basically batch job code glue
code and you know it's worth thinking
about if I have a platform that does all
this for me and I can operate at this
higher level I can move much more
quickly and not keep resolving this
problem and you can apply it sort of
anyplace you need to do this kind of
this kind of computation so if you get
all the way there you're living the
dream
it's unicorns and rainbows right so
that's the talk do you think the issues
that you ran into with the community
operators are a sign that that approach
is fundamentally the wrong one or is it
just that the project's immature and
they haven't been built out yet and if
the ladder
have you tried contributing back to the
project and what was that like for
airflow rate so it's a good question I
mean you can make things work right so
you could probably take you could take
one of two paths with this sort of thing
you can find a way through making the
black box thing work for you and make
the set of compromises you need to make
the path I felt was much more productive
for us was this the ladder path I
described of just taking control of that
and finding sort of the minimal shim to
connect to air flow and go in that
direction and give you know basically
take all the general stuff from the
framework that I don't want to build and
where we want to
trol keep control right sort of like
standard way to think about buy versus
build in terms of your question of
contributing back I did open an issue
about the headers thing and then it was
fixed in a later version so to that
degree yes you mentioned earlier about a
using a declarative interface on top of
air flow do you have any examples of any
tooling out there that is trying to do
that so you don't have to write all the
code yourself right I don't know of any
projects that are in wide use that are
doing that yet I was at a meet-up
recently and actually it was meetup
itself we're talking about how they're
how they're handling this and it was
basically like here's a yamo that
describes my job and it was over both
the dag and and the database
dependencies and sort of though where it
was going to run and I do think that's a
sort of obvious direction that this is
going to go in and should go in I also
know of you know friends at other larger
internet companies they're working on
the same idea I mean the way I say this
to people is that this is sort of this
this is sort of like the assembly
language of data pipelines still right
like I mean also there's a some folks I
don't know the name off top my head but
they're writing languages that are sort
of data pipeline languages that's
another way to deal put a higher level
abstraction on the same set of problems
as baked in right into a language sort
of for example accessing resources and
so on but I mean this idea of having to
carefully assemble all the steps step by
step by step it's does it does not feel
like the end point to me at all what
what a made you go with data pipeline in
the first place and and I don't know it
do you regret that decision now that you
have to cut over to airflow so we're now
getting into my personal history at
beeswax so that did that decision
predated me I regretted it that it had
ever been made very quickly but that
said you know you you can make like
we're engineers you can make things work
so data pipeline really it by the time I
got there we had this built out our own
set of primitives to operate with it in
a reasonable way you know like so we had
wrappers for putting the our code in a
container and putting that out somewhere
we knew how to run task Runner and
almost never had to think about it and
we had wrappers around basically the
making the pipeline piece so that the
scheduler knew about it and having it
you know all the config and dependencies
all be wrapped up in a continue like we
had solve that it's just that the you
know the gap my point in the talk was
more the gap between what it promises
and what it delivers is very similar
with these two things even though one
for the claims of you managed service
the others a new open source project and
you know you kind of end up in a lot of
the same place with both have you looked
into AWS glue at all and would you
consider that as an alternative to
airflow or or not so interesting I
actually did look at it around this time
and tried to build something with it
it felt immature in a couple ways the UI
was painful and sort of slow and a
little bit unreliable maybe but you know
okay but also we ran into some race
conditions relying on it as well in
terms of sort of not really read your
own rights but like read your own DDL
rights like and so we just felt like it
was a little what and and again it was
very high level you I was like a
extremely simplistic web informatica
maybe kind of it seemed like my take on
it was it was targeting more of an
enterprise use case where we wanted
again you know it's like the same thing
to buy versus build we wanted a lot more
control over the execution part of this
problem anymore quick
if you guys consider other tax managers
like Luigi or woozi or whatever great so
I did look at Luigi just in terms of the
features and I I liked that airflow had
a more kind of complete feature set this
was at the point where I thought I was
gonna get everything out of that but I
still think you know I haven't done a
lot of Luigi do really say but that was
kind of my take on it then any final
questions we got one over here yeah
thanks for the talk so just a design
question you decided to you know base
off of the base operator um why not just
go with the you know extend the redshift
to s3 operator you mentioned you know
the security thing was a concern but did
you just dismiss everything else or do
you guys just have other operators that
you want to work on right so that's a
great question so this is a question
kind of between was I solving just that
specific problem in the moment are going
for a more general a solution so what I
decided was that we want what we already
knew we needed for example just for this
pipeline a hive operator we're looking
at wanting operators to spin up EMR
clusters and spark and you know other
other things down the road so what I was
looking for was a general solution to
the problem that would let us build out
other operators and and solve this
problem of being able to customize all
of them in certain ways with one pattern
and let each of them customize
themselves specifically if they needed
to so that was kind of why I went with
the inherit from the base operator and
let us build out our operators it
doesn't preclude us from using any can't
operators that perfectly fit our needs
it's just the dag just constructs one of
those and you know you're good but to
kind of get us out of this brittleness
into a place where we
felt we had the flexibility to move
forward confidently knowing we can't add
this open flexibility that's why I went
with that approach
[Music]